i'm putting plastic beads and lead shot
into a cylinder so now i'm going to
shake this
in the same way
and of course being a theoretician it's
not going to work
but after a while you can begin to see
regions where it's darker and regions
where it's red and you'll keep doing
this for a while
i'm going to be talking about what's
called the brazil nut effect and in that
there's a capital gamma which is
somewhat like a hangman's
gibbet
is the ratio
of
acceleration
to gravity
well let's suppose i shake this up and
down
gravity acting downwards has an
acceleration of 9.8 meters per second
if i raise this up slowly
then nothing much moves but if i shake
it violently at the top part there's an
acceleration and the packet inside will
hit the top of the box so you'll hear it
rattling up and down so the brazil nut
effect comes
i think it was first thought of in about
1930
people noticed that if you had a packet
of cereal such as this one which is
mosley
when you open the packet of mosley first
thing in the morning
the heavier particles the big ones are
on the top you've got
well i can point out a brazil nut there
and a cashew nut and some raisins and
down the bottom it's all mixed up but if
i keep shaking it like this
eventually you will find at the top
and it'll take quite a while there's an
almond nut and there's a cashew nut and
all the big particles come there or your
you got your coffee instant coffee and
it's you shake it up just to mix it all
up and you'll find the bigger grains
going on the top and the smaller ones
underneath that's what you're trying to
do when you when you mix up your cereal
you're trying to get it uniformly spread
but when you try and do these things
nature plays a trick on you but it
doesn't go the way you would imagine let
me just show you this nice simple
demonstration
here i've got
grains they're green and a little steel
ball on the top
so if i arrange matters so the steel
ball is on the bottom
and i shake this up and down for about
10-15 seconds after a while you'll
notice the ball has come
to the top
it's a ratcheting effect the smaller
particles get underneath it then you
throw it up more small particles get
underneath it it goes up to the top here
we have two plates of glass separated by
a gap about three millimeters with
little glass spheres and we put bigger
particles we used aluminium particles
but these are steel washers roughly the
same size and put them in there
originally the research student duncan
saunders did the computing and he said
you put them in there and they're all
clustered together and we have a video
showing his computed results and so the
computed results suggested that these
particles would come together like a
little form of bees
and cluster around each other in the
middle which is quite the opposite of
what you'd expect because what you want
to do when you're shaking this up is
make everything as dispersed as possible
so we did the experiment nobody believed
that you could actually do
the experiment and the results are shown
in the in the video and it starts out
with particles which are reasonably
close together and you shake it up and
after a while they act like a little
form of bees all buzzing around each
other
and i'd like to show you finally
this experiment i did it a couple of
days ago i'm putting plastic beads and
lead shot into a cylinder the red ones
are the plastic beads the black ones are
the tiny little pieces of lead they have
the same sizes and you shake this about
and you try and mix it up and you can't
do it but it's relatively well
mixed and i can use the same parameter
gamma i now have the horizontal version
of acceleration which we always measure
in terms of gravity
and then you put in a little bit of
water not a lot
just a little bit
and you see the water going in
filling through the whole cell right
down to the bottom
and now you have
beads moving in water
which you would think that's not going
to make any difference
so now i'm going to shake this
in the same way
and of course being a theoretician it's
not going to work
but after a while you can begin to see
regions where it's darker and regions
where it's red and you keep doing this
for a while
and you find patterns emerging
it's black red black red black red black
red black red it goes into stripes so
you have a mechanism for
pattern formation but why it turns out
to be these particular spacing between
is a bit of a mystery is that five
minutes
yep well done